au nicaragua l'armée poursuit son
offensive contre les villes où sont
installés les rebelles sandiniste depuis
hier l'aviation est intervenue à
plusieurs reprises pour soutenir la taxe
de la garde nationale
sur le plan politique l'action du
président du nicaragua est cependant de
plus en plus précaires les états unis
aimeraient que les combats cessent par
l'intermédiaire de l'organisation des
états américains il tente en ce moment
d'intervenir comme médiateur au
nicaragua les appelle les muchachos les
enfants ce sont eux qui encadrés par
leurs aînés font aujourd'hui la
révolution contre somoza nous n'avons
rien la seule chose qui nous reste c'est
de lutter pour une patrie libre depuis
dix jours à l'appel du front sandiniste
ils ont déclenché l'insurrection armée
dans plusieurs villes du pays mais la
garde nationale est intervenue
massivement avec les blindés et
l'aviation et le mouvement que certains
croyaient décisif s'est transformée
aujourd'hui en un combat meurtrier dont
l'issue reste incertaine
après 45 années de dictature le pays
tout entier semble s'être crispé dans
une réaction de rejet à laquelle
s'associent maintenant l'église
catholique dont l'influencé considérable
adversaires de somoza l'archevêque de
managua réfugiés au costa rica décrit ce
que pourrait être la meilleure solution
pour son pays
tout d'abord ce sont les laïcs qui
doivent trouver la solution de ce
problème cruel et ce qu'il faut avant
tout c'est la paix
la passe et non pas la paix des
cimetières ou bien une paix imposée par
les tanks ou les mitraillettes
mais une paix dynamique à laquelle tout
le monde pourrait participer dans le
respect des droits de ce psp sera
d'autant plus difficile qu'il ya eu
violence des deux côtés et que déjà
beaucoup de sang a coulé
il est difficile de faire un bilan mais
on parle de plus de 500 morts et un
millier de blessés
des villes ont été bombardés par
l'aviation la loi martiale proclamé dans
tout le pays
la grève générale continue et sur les
routes les réfugiés affluent pour
prendre de vitesse le front sandiniste
considéré comme marxisant les etats-unis
demandent maintenant la médiation de
l'organisation des états américains
voilà ce que tout le pays demande et
nous les premiers c'est la
démocratisation de notre peuple
la solution face à somoza et osmosis mme
c'est un gouvernement national qui
regroupe tous les courants dans un
gouvernement provisoire qui crée les
conditions pour des élections libres et
honnêtes
aux etats unis la libérale du congrès
appui carter dans sa politique des
droits de l'homme il pourrait y avoir
une volte-face américaine contre somoza
malgré tout nous sommes pessimistes
contre somoza il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que le fer et le plomb est
temps pour les mots quelle autre
démocratie perd contre plomelin gouaille
contre les opposants
noailles thaïlande définitive n'était
préparé mon coeur est à noël et elle
combien savons bien que ce n'est que le
commencement ce sont les toutes
premières luttes
ce qui est certain c'est que notre
peuple est décidée à lutter doit
apprendre la guerre en faisant la guerre
vous n'allez rapporte c'est une guerre
populaire prolongée pendant ce temps
enfermé dans son bunker à managua somoza
joue sa dernière carte
il attend la victoire une victoire qui
tarde à venir